بحب ادي من هذه العباره
الاجتهاد في تطوير الذات طريق النجاح
واطرح من خلالها السؤال مهم
الى شبابنا
توقيت صفري تعتقدوه صحيح للبدء بالاعداد
والتهير لمقابله عمل
في احد الصباحات
استقبل ابراهيم اللي هو طالب في المرحله
الرابعه اتصال هاتفي يبلغ انه بكره عنده
مقابله عمل
الموضوع كان شيء مفاجئ طالب بالمرحله
الرابعه تتصل بشركه تطلب منه مقابله عمل
وقت قصير للاعداد بدل كل المحاولات والجهد
راح ثاني يوم ابراهيم للمقابله لكن للاسف
الامور ما مشت بالشكل الصحيح
تلك كثير
بالحديث بالاسئله بالاجوبه
ومرت عليه لحظات طويله لحظات كان يتمنى ان
تنتهي ويخلص من هذا المازق اللي هو بيه
وبعث ثواني رن جرس المنبه ليعلن انها
الساعه 7:00 صباحا ابراهيم كان نايم
والموضوع كان حلم وهو اصلا طالب مقبول في
الكليه هذه سنه الاولى لازم يروح للجامعه
حتى يكمل اجراءات التسجيل
في هذه اللحظه ابراهيم فرح يعني الازمن
انتهت لكن في نفس الوقت سوى شيء كلش مهم
اعتبر هذه اللحظه لحظه مهمه بحياته لان
نشا معاها وعي وتفكير بهاي النقطه البعيده
اللي نعتقدها بعيده اربع سنوات او خمس
سنوات
وفي نفس الوقت طرح ابراهيم سؤال مهم جدا
على نفسه شنو اللي لازم اسويه حتى اتهيا
لهذا اليوم
خلال تجربتي مع ال
قناه تجربه 20 سنه في قطاع التعليم العالي
الحاله الحاله هي غياب الوعي ونقول غياب
شنو نقصد به غياب الوعي غياب الوعي باهميه
هذا اليوم لدى لا تستغربون معظم شبابنا ما
يعرف انه هذا اليوم قريب ولا متهيا له ولا
يفكر به سؤال ليش اقول لك ممكن لان نتعلم
يتعين
بدوائر الدوله
ومنظومه القطاع العام ما تعطي اكثر من 20%
لمهارات المتقدم اي واحد اثنين اصلا
المؤسساتنا التعليميه ما كانت مهتمه بشكل
اساسي بهذه النقطه قبل 2017 لان 2017
شكلت عندنا تشكيله جديد اللي هو وحده
التاهيل والتوظيف اللي اهتمت بهذا الموضوع
طيب شنو اللي صار قبل 2017
التفتنا الى هذه النقطه وبدينا نشتغل على
هذا الموضوع اللي سويناه رحنا الى الشركات
القطاع الخاص قلنا لهم تعالوا احكوا لنا
انتم شنو تحتاجون
نسويه للطالب شلون نجهزه لكم شنو متطلبات
سوق العمل فعلا
سمعنا لهم سوينا التواصل
ووصلنا الى اربع محاور اساسيه
ومهمه لابد انه يشتغل عليها كل شاب وكل
طالب المحور الاول اللي يمثل
العلوم او المعرفه هذا موضوع مسؤوله عليه
الجامعه اللي لازم تطور منها
وتحدثها بشكل يواكب سوق العمل وتتاكد من
تنفيذها بالشكل السليم والصحيح اللي همم
يعني يضمن نجاحها هذا من جهه جهه الثانيه
وهذه نقطه مهمه واعتقد اهميتها ظهرت بعد
2003 وهي اللغه الانجليزيه اللغه
الانجليزيه هي بوابه لدخول اي وظيفه
بالوقت الحاضر وهذا الجهد لازم يبدل
الطالب نفسه حتى يقدر
بيكون جاهز لهذا اليوم ولهذا الموعد مع اي
مقابله في حياه المهنيه
النقطه الثالثه والمحور الثالث وهو بناء
الشخصيه وتعزيز الثقه بالنفس هنانه رسالتي
الى العائله اقول لهم هذا دوركم بناء
الشخصيه ما يخلص بيوم ولا بيومين ولا بشهر
هذا مسؤولين عليه انتم من عند ما يكون
ابنكم او بنتكم لا زالت في المهد والازال
الطفله الى ان تتطور الامور ونقدر نوصلهم
الى مرحله مهمه وهو المحور الرابع وهو
يكونوا قادرين يملكون مهارات الاداره
والقياده اللطيف كثير من يسمع مهارات
قياده واداره يقول هو ماخذ منصب مدير عام
حتى يحتاجها اقول لك
كل انسان يحتاج مهارات الاداره والقياده
سواء رب الاسره سواء الطالب سواء ربه
الاسراء السائق اللي يسوق سياره لازم يكون
عنده مهارات حتى يقود سياره يوصلني الى بر
الامان
طيب
انتهينا من هذه المحاور باشرنا
بالتنفيذ تواصلنا
وحققنا
نجاحات جدا مهمه اثناء التنفيذ لكن
بالحقيقه واجهتنا تحديات تحدي الاول شركات
القطاع الخاص ما كانت تثق بالجامعات
ماكو تواصل سابق ماكو تفاهم سابق بيناتنا
فكان تحدي اول وصعب التحدي الثاني
الناينسات التفكير الطالب
ماكو طالب ماكو خريج يقبل يتعين بشركه
قطاع خاص اكو تعيين حكومي يعني تعيين
حكومي اسهل اضمن الى اخره وعشنا في صراع
في هذه المرحله
في اجتياز هذه العقبه والحمد لله حصلنا
على نتائج ممتازه جدا بعد ان اقنعنا شركات
القطاع الخاص انا تساهم بتدريب ما يقارب
ال 400 طالب
وساهمنا بشكل فعال ومهم بايجاد وظائف الى
اكثر من 300 طالب
حققنا شراكه وصداقه جدا مهمه مع 25 شركه
في القطاع الخاص
وهذه الصوره تمثل الدفعه الاولى اللي
انجزت عمليه التدريب في شهر تموز اااه في
شركه ويذر فورد اللي اسجل باسمها اول نجاح
في هذا المجال
[تصفيق]
الاهم من هاي الارقام كلها شنو
بالنسبه الي كا اكاديمي الشيء المهم
الالهام للطالب الصغير انا من اكون طالب
بالمرحله الاولى واشوف طالب المرحله
الرابعه عند فرصه انه يحصل وظيفه
شنو اللي يمنعني انه اوصل الى هذا المستوى
حتى حصل الوظيفه
كل شيء مهم هاي النقطه وصلت تاثير ليس
للمرحله الاولى طالب المرحله الاولى نزلنا
حتى الى مستوى اعداديه رسالتنا وصلت الحمد
لله
[موسيقى]
وكان عندنا مقياس للتاثير من خلال تحسن
اداء الطلبه اثناء المقابلات بالاعوام
اللاحقه
في نهايه حديثي احب اوصل اوجه رسالتين
الرساله الاولى الى عوائلنا الكريمه
وطلبتنا وطلبتي واحبتي الاعزاء اقول لهم
فرص العمل موجوده لكن تحتاج تشتهر وتكون
مؤهل بشكل صحيح حتى تاخدها اي واحد
الرساله الثانيه اللي احب اوجهها الى
شركات القطاع الخاص واقولهم
الطاقه الشبابيه اللي تحتاجوها بعملكم
موجوده عندنا موجوده في جامعاتنا موجوده
في كلياتنا كل اللي عليكم اهلا وسهلا
تعالوا تواصلوا مع شعب التاهيل والتوظيف
وراحت تحصلون البيانات اللي تخدمكم وراح
تختارون افضل شخص لانسب مهمه
واحب ادعوهم بشكل جاد
لدعم التدريب لان
الاستثمار في البشر مشروع ابدا ما يخسر
وهو سر الازدهار شكرا لحسن استماعكم
ودعوات القلبيه لطلبتي واحبتي واعزائي
الشباب بالتوفيق والنجاح
[تصفيق]